something else it's calling me
everybody hopefully you've had a chance
to see the movie by now this is gonna be
my breakdown of some of the deleted
scenes that the director and the
producers have revealed they said that
there'd be about 20 minutes of footage
that they'd add to the DVD so a lot of
these have finished CG they just cut
them out at the very last minute for
time or because they were slowing the
movie down it's still a two and a half
hour long movie making it the longest
Star Wars movie of all time so when I
explain these it'll make complete sense
why they had to come out of the film
like oh yeah people would have been even
more pissed about that one particular
scene but if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
everything
there's a whole bunch we have to get
through before the end of the year I'm
still doing that IMAX ticket giveaway in
because I didn't say it at the beginning
of the video just careful for spoilers
from episode 8 because we will have to
address some of the specific moments but
starting with some of the bigger stuff
they said that there was a lot of Finn
rows and DJs character while they were
on their way to Snoke ship that they cut
out Rian Johnson said and I'm quoting
him when I say this again I will give
the caveat that the movie is still
better as a whole without any of them
but yeah man there was some great stuff
there's a whole extended sequence where
Finn and Rose and DJ sneak through the
mega Destroyer which is the supremacy
that's the actual name of Snoke Star
Destroyer after they sneak in with DJ
and they try to find the tracker it's a
full sequence of them sneaking around
through this big office area of the mega
destroyer and then having to fake out
these stormtroopers so you can see right
away why they cut that out because even
though it was a great scene that totally
worked in the moment in the finished
film it just gave too much weight to
those characters there was already too
much footage of them compared to the
other storylines and it's really
supposed to be Luke Skywalker's film his
big moment where he spreads the legend
and gives hope to everyone so maybe they
will join Leia's resistance there's a
whole other video that I have to make
about Luke Skywalker the director
actually explained very specifically
what was going on in his head when he
wrote that moment where Luke showed up
as a for spirit why he did what he did
in why it was so important for him that
he died in this film in not in episode 9
even though JJ Abrams is free to do
pretty much whatever he wants he doesn't
have to focus on the same characters in
the way that Rian Johnson did but he
does have to hit
some really big signposts so I will link
my episode 9 video at the end of this
but some of the biggest complaints that
I saw on my review video in the Star
Wars videos that I've been posting the
last couple of days is that people
really did not like Benicio del Toro
stutter and they didn't like how much
they favor those characters over Luke
Skywalker Rey in kylo Ren scenes but
surprisingly a lot of these other
deleted scenes are from awk - they're
either raisins or they're Luke training
Rey's scenes so people are probably more
upset that they cut those but they will
make it onto the DVD then he goes on and
I'm quoting him when he says and then
they're on the island there's this
massive sequence that we shot with Daisy
and Mark which is kind of an additional
sort of trial test that she goes through
that involves her mark and then this big
emotional scene between the two of them
what he's talking about are those three
Jedi lessons that Luke said that he
would give to Rey there were a lot of
people after the movie that were
confused because we only see a couple of
the lessons like he says in the morning
I'll give you three lessons and explain
to you why it's important that the Jedi
need to end and we really only get the
first lesson and in the last lesson
before he explains why the Jedi need to
end but we never found out what that or
the lesson was and it just deleted
scenes so it's basically him giving her
the basics of the force like when
obi-wan was first teaching Luke first he
puts the blaster helmet on and he starts
to feel with the force then later an
empire when he's on Dagobah he learns
about the force cave so ray gets a lot
of those same lessons that Luca just
albeit in different forms I'm not afraid
[Music]
you will be you will be there was
another long scene between Ray and the
caretakers on the island remember she
just continually pissed them off more
and more destroying parts of their Hut
with blaster fire chopping up pieces of
the island destroying their work just
creating a lot more for them to do so
they were just incredibly annoyed with
her is they climb up to the Jedi Temple
she says I get the feeling that they
don't like me very much
in Luke jokes I can't imagine why so
there were scenes before that happened
where she just did more things to piss
them off and try to apologize there was
another big scene with Finn and Poe at
the beginning of the film where he is
leaking and he comes in and it's this
really funny scene where they try to get
him centered before he starts asking
questions about Rey they say it's kind
of a setup scene at the beginning where
Poe was kind of bringing Finn up to
speed after he comes out of his coma God
there's a bunch of really fun stuff we
talk more about them when the blu-ray
comes out but I'm excited for folks to
see them talking about all the deleted
scenes so this was taken a while ago
they've already done the commentary for
the blu-ray track Rian Johnson actually
posted a picture of himself as he said
he was sitting down to record the
commentary track but when it comes time
to picking the bonus features that go on
the blu-ray they go through all the
deleted scenes because there's hours and
hours of things that they could put on
it but really only about 20 minutes
worth of solid finished scenes that
actually looked like they belong in the
movie and it's not just alternate
versions of scenes that you've already
seen it's a completely different stuff
that it just lifts it out of the film
because it wasn't absolutely necessary
but a lot of you will joke that you
could cut a lot of that canto bites
stuff out of the movie and it would
still work because it's really
predicated on the idea that Admiral hole
dough with holes a bunch of information
from Poe's character so he starts that
resistance within the resistance that
creates the need for them to go to canto
bite where as if she had told him the
truth at the beginning then they
wouldn't have needed the secret plan to
go get DJ but it would basically cut
them out of the film and a lot of people
are wondering about john boyega's
character because now that finn has
effectively taken care of phasma there's
not a whole lot for him to do like he's
a member of the resistance so he'll just
go out on missions with Poe Dameron
who's taking more of a leadership role
but in terms of his arc he's come full
circle like he leaves the first order
he leaves phasma his commander then
comes back tries to help the resistance
and in doing so confronts or defeats her
and it's all said and done the one with
the unresolved arc right now is array
because she has to consider what the
future of the Jedi Order is going to be
what path is she going to take she needs
to repair that lightsaber
she needs to confront kylo Ren again so
if you were disappointed that Rey and
the force users didn't get that much
story during last Jedi that's gonna be
very different during episode 9 because
you have this big space battle between
the two different fleets but then you
also have the final confrontation with
Ray in kylo Ren so it'll be interesting
to see how they weave in the other side
characters into this like rows in Finn
like what are they gonna be doing while
this stuff is going on because the path
of rain kylo Ren just seemed a lot more
clear at this point we know what kylo
Ren wants he wants Rey and he wants to
bring order to the galaxy and we know
what Ray wants she wants to find her
place in all this and bring balance to
the force whatever form that takes
but hopefully that explains why they cut
some of those deleted scenes Justice
League was a different scenario that's a
movie where they cut a bunch of stuff
out to get the movie down under two
hours that was not the case with Star
Wars the last Jedi
they just cut that stuff out because
they felt like it hurt the story like it
slowed things down even more than they
were already slowed down at certain
points but my next Star Wars video will
probably be about Luke Skywalker because
the director has revealed so much about
that from behind the scenes so it's
actually pretty fascinating the way he
envisioned it depending on whether or
not people received it that way is a
different matter but congratulations to
the latest ticket giveaway winner
dragons 1608 please private message me
on the back into my channel so I can get
your contact details I'll just do a new
round when I post new Star Wars you can
click here to learn all about the
Episode nine title and you can click
here for all my last Jedi Easter eggs
and cameos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight